I'm not really a New Year's resolution
person we don't really look even at what
we did for the year for our stats and
everything will look month over month
how do we do it compared to last year
but I'm much more into micro adjustments
than I am into big annual adjustments I
think the great thing about New Year's
is hey use it in December to plan for
January cool but why wait you know like
I think we're too much in the waiting
business like okay I'm gonna wait like
whatever your New Year's resolution is
how about you start right now like why
wait till January in general we wait too
long we wait for our birthday we wait
for Monday we wait for January 1st we
wait for after Thanksgiving I'll get it
going or after the summer that's when
I'll go going or in the new year it's
too cold in the spring like there's
always something to wait on and for me
as soon as I come up with any kind of
thing that's anywhere close to New
Year's resolution so hey well it's
December 8th let's start right now and
that becomes the thinking I think one of
the things that helped me the most on
this is I have daily habits and I want
the daily habits to lead to the outcomes
that I want you know like why do this
how long have we been doing this when
did build serve come out four years ago
I don't know like why keep doing this
well because I love you guys and and I
want to see you progress and this is fun
and it fills my heart but if nobody
showed up okay well you know I guess
we're done and and we'll do something
else anytime you feel something's off
like your habits will likely change next
year and hopefully like maybe you need a
big reset shift but but a lot of times
with habits it's a small shift
and if you don't make the small shift
and small adjustments then at some point
you have to go make a big adjustment
right like people have a midlife crisis
like they weren't making enough small
adjustments as they came up until they
hit the point where they just absolutely
hate their life and have to do something
drastic
and so what I try to do is pay much more
attention to the small shifts whether
that's things like diet or making videos
or content or hiring people like small
shifts in what I'm doing and and that
comes from recognizing small
frustrations
in your life
and then making a shift in your habits
as opposed to waiting for some big thing
to happen or for some special occasion
happen for you to then have to take some
kind of action so yeah in those I think
you grow as a human you're growing and
learning you're on this upward scale but
if you stay stuck with your habits then
the person you want to be is no longer
in alignment with the person who you are
and like how big a ship does that make
because you're going to continue to
evolve and grow but if you keep the same
habits that you have and never shift
then you that that Delta will be bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and you'll get more and more and
more and more and more frustrated to the
point where you have a breaking point
and I I don't want to have breaking
points I want to notice a small shift
and then make a small change in another
small ship to make a small change
I'm just having these um need for a CRM
and uh for for my for my company and uh
we've been checking some and uh we've
been checking Soho which is uh one that
we've been using so far
um but I based on all what I've learned
here I think that uh we really need a
better way to manage
um leads and you know create our library
of of uh emails and all that that we
don't really we didn't really have that
so uh one of the projects for this year
is to become more efficient in managing
the the that part the uh the sales part
the funnel and all that right so we've
been checking Monday
um so far we've been using Soho but not
in a really efficient way I would say so
we've been using it more to to record
what's going on on the processing part
because we need to keep records of
everything that happens when we deal
with a file so we've been using it for
that for administrative things let's say
but not for sales and uh it doesn't look
that efficient for me that doesn't look
that easy to use Soho so um if you
receive a large number of leads but not
all of them are real because they are
not real or potential clients but you
still want to have them because it may
not be for right now but maybe for later
those can be clients
um and you want to have all this process
this sales process under control all and
well Direction what CRM it's a you know
advisable
um I don't I don't know that I have a
recommended CRM for you I think
ultimately comes down to how much do you
want to learn this stuff and get great
at it
like do you want to be the person who
learns CRM and dives into comparing one
software with another software with
another software
are you excited about that you say no
hey
foreign
so the the usually for most of these
things
um
any of them are good enough to get you
to the next level
if you just use it and they may not be
perfect and maybe you're you're losing
leads places yes
but the goal then becomes if you don't
want to get great at this then is
anybody else in the company willing to
get great at this
yeah well this is the thing we need to
use one because otherwise we are losing
the leads like we are not having a good
use of it like we're not sometimes we
don't know what happened with uh this or
that person that contacted us because
um there's no clear system to register
them that the one that we've been using
it's very manual so we would like
something a little bit more
you know more uh that helps us to have a
good track okay but do you or somebody
on the team want to get great at this
uh it's it's uh we do right now a person
that it's uh in charge of marketing and
it's also uh the person that will be the
most familiar with the CRM and uh but we
all need to use it
I got it but to the person designed all
this stuff the marketing person
Is Not Great yet because they haven't
told you what to do so does the
marketing person want to get great at
this and do you trust that they can be
great at this
yes I think that he can do a a good job
though and actually he is trying to he's
familiar with Monday that's probably why
he has been introducing us to that one
he knows that one and uh but I've
listened about so many that I was
thinking maybe there is a suggestion
that I should look into
um because it's you know something that
has been working well for some other
members
but I think yes he can he can yeah he
can be good at it to guide the rest
if he's if if he's already an expert on
Monday
and you well okay so so step one could
be find all the other CRM programs and
do an analysis and figure out which one
we're going to use and ultimately it
comes down to somebody has to become
great at this thing either internally or
somebody who is going to come in from
the outside and even just consult and
set it up for you so for example if I
look at my setup here right like what
camera do I use I don't know what's this
microphone no idea what light is this I
don't know what the angle is no idea
right like I don't want to be the expert
at this up have zero interest in doing
it
um and uh Zach actually helped
fix this so we did a session movement
makers he did a whole gear thing he's
like hey Evan your gear could be better
cool what should I buy
and I I bought the camera the Fujifilm
camera and the whatever this is however
that is and I bought what he told me to
buy and set it up the way that he told
me to set it up and hopefully it looks
good
I don't know but I don't want to be an
expert at that but I also don't need a
Zack in every day doing this thing for
me right it's like come in tell me what
I need help me set it up and then if I
have questions I'll let you know but it
doesn't need to be somebody who's doing
it all the time right so somebody could
come in and tell you how to do something
and set you up that you're paying an
outside consultant on but that's much
assuming you're making some money in
your business that's a much better use
of your time than you trying to figure
out Monday versus something else versus
something else versus something else
right if you have somebody on the team
who's willing to learn and wants to make
this their their passion their career
their expertise cool then you don't have
to go outside you already have somebody
if they have enough knowledge great you
run with it if not then they can go and
do all the research to find all the
different serum like their tasks for the
next week is go figure out every single
CRM
and what we're going to use as best for
our company
look at Monday look at Salesforce look
at click funnels look at all the other
ones
you go do the work and come back and
tell me which one we should use and why
and almost all of them will do
um like there's maybe some that
completely suck and hopefully he can
eliminate those but a lot of your
business is not super complicated
this is like what email software do I
use they're almost all the same there's
different ways and different buttons and
different clicks and different things
you have to point to but they're they do
the basic things like following up with
leads is something every CRM does right
otherwise they're not a CRM like what
are we using this for and so which
software you should use is the one that
your team is most capable of using
right because you're not going to be the
one doing it so it's someone on the team
right like if if it was just you solo
Tanya by yourself you're probably using
Excel or something right like Excel
spreadsheet of all the clients and you
follow up with them because it's an easy
business to manage but now that you have
team
it's the it's the tool that you're going
to use
so when Nick came in and started helping
um with with my website and stuff he's
like I don't want to use aweber I want
to use entreport
okay
cool we use entrepoint because he has to
do all the stuff
right so cool I'm used to aweber but
it's all a game it's email marketing
it's all the same stuff he likes these
features better amazing you know how to
use entreport go use entreport we use
click funnels he knows how to use click
funnels right but if we stock The Click
funnels and I love Nick and he said I
hate click funnels I want to use kajabi
okay
move to kajabi I don't care
Dan is unhappy uh I love both because
Russell is Click funnels and Brendan is
good job he's uh you know I love both of
them but it's really more about the team
uh who like who's in charge and
can they use the tool and teach other
people how to use a tool yeah
right and so if he already knows Monday
and he loves that great if not like go
do the work find the list and then
he's basically in charge of leading it
for the team and this is assuming you
like this you like him you trust him he
can be great amazing then you give him
the responsibility to
to run it and in the teach you guys
because if he even if if Monday only
does 75 of the things that you do that
you need but he's great at those like
he's great at Monday and figures it out
that will serve your business way more
than moving to some other software that
nobody knows how to use and the time in
in thinking and planning
especially for you it's just not worth
it because you need to be talking to
clients you need to be building the
brand you got to be making content you
got to be doing so many more
efficient things than
figuring out a CRM software
yeah
it makes sense thank you it's a great
place to be and I think one of the
biggest struggles we face as
entrepreneurs is at the beginning
you have to remember the why like why
are we doing this like for any solo
entrepreneur part-time entrepreneur we
have to remember the why behind what
we're doing because we get demotivated
and we're not working as hard as we can
and we have a great day and then the
next day is not so great and then we
forget and we fall off when we don't
believe that we can do it and we just
don't have the motivation right to think
back to everybody and some of you might
be in that spot now but you think back
to when you were starting not every day
was amazing and not every day you were
crushing it not every day you had hope
and belief that you were doing it
um because you were getting started and
so the why is the most important thing
to think about
The Next Step becomes the how where
you're doing everything like from you
move from y to how
so you had some kind of CRM software
Tanya but it was just like Excel or a
word doc or a email or something like
you kept track a client somehow it
wasn't efficient it wasn't a built-in
tool but we have to we have to figure
out the how for all of this stuff at the
beginning right you don't have money to
hire anybody you don't have anybody on
your team and so you have to do
everything and we try to figure out how
to get something done and that's where a
lot of entrepreneurs will struggle is
like I've got the passion in something
but I don't know how well you don't have
money so you invest your time or you
invest your money you have to figure out
the how to at least just get things
going this isn't where how it's going to
look in five years but we just got to
get things going right just to like film
with your phone instead of a fancy setup
but then the third shift then becomes
The Who so it's like from the Y to the
how to the who like who's going to help
me do this and as you build and scale
your business we need to stop asking how
questions and more who questions
so who's going to help me run the CRM
because you're still thinking how
like which CRM is a how question
that prevents you from doing the things
that you're great at this is a who
question so it's either the guy on my
team who's going to help me do this or
I'm going to hire somebody who's an
expert at this to come in not full-time
but to help me set this up and even if
you hired an expert and it's going to
cost you five thousand dollars to have
somebody come in and set this up for you
and understand your business and give
you the right strategy to do that five
thousand dollars worth so much more than
you
trying to figure out the how and trying
to tried all these softwares and look at
YouTube videos and read the manuals and
on and on and on and then try to
implement for the team is just becomes
this it's a cost saving measure but it
it's a even bigger opportunity cost loss
of what you should be doing with your
time right so
um
yeah I mean we use click funnels we use
entrepour we use aweber but who cares
what we use like so moving from the the
why to the how to then The Who
for you now becomes a lot more about
like who's going to help me on the
things that I don't care about but I
need so that I can focus on the things
that I love
yes and I I like that approach because
it regardless where we are I think that
we always keep to thinking and why why
I'm doing this like we go through
different phases as an entrepreneurs but
the why it's kind of our guide
we always have to keep thinking on that
and I like that what you said so yes
it's cool to have that this problem I
guess right now about who can do it and
and uh yes
yeah that's a good moment cool
and thank you for sharing coach Cassie
says I've been that person for the last
five years trying to figure it all out
by myself it's just not the right
solution trust me well listen when
you're at that stage it depends on if
you have any money coming in or not
right like if you have no money you have
to be the hell person and you do your
best with what you've got and you try to
figure it out and it's going to be it's
gonna be ugly and it's gonna be
inefficient and it's gonna suck in a lot
of spots and the goal becomes High to
wide just work my magic enough to be
good enough at the thing that I can sell
so I can make some money so I can afford
to hire people to help me with the
things that I really just suck at
um
the the danger is staying in the how
mode when you should move to who
right like if you if Tanya invested
nashiri has a guy which is great and if
she didn't and she invested two thousand
dollars four thousand dollars five
thousand dollars to have somebody help
her figure this piece out that's gonna
that's gonna pay itself off easily that
might pay itself off with the first
email she sends out because she hasn't
been followed with leads properly
and that next person pays her the five
thousand dollars that she just invested
not lost but invested into that person
that helped her set up the system
right so that's how you shortcut your
path that's how you start to grow a lot
faster is moving from the how to the who
the hell yeah and I just want a quick
thing I
um
I've always seen that it's uh it's one
of the goals when I became an
entrepreneur is being able to create
more employment opportunities for people
and uh yes I'm happy that last month we
hire our people number 12 so we have now
a team of 12 people and that's kind of
like a big gift a Christmas gift for me
because it's a kind of it's like sharing
the goodness and it's awesome so I as as
soon as I was able to move from that
part that me doing everything uh to
start hiring someone to do it uh I
started doing it and we've been going
slowly and slowly but now we are in this
point and we have a team of people and I
totally believe what you're saying it's
important to to make people to give the
opportunity for them to do what they can
do better and you focus on something
else but this CRM thing was you know
bringing me like yeah he was asking my
input and I was like I don't know I'm
gonna try to find out but that's a shift
like if he's asking for your input
it's then not you trying to figure out
how it's one empowering him to go and
figure out how and say hey I trust you
like you go do the research and getting
the information out of you as to what
you need
he may not know all of the business
objectives or the business goals or
where you want to take the company that
might help pick one platform over
another but this is now as you're
managing a team and like amazing
congrats on 12 people it's it's awesome
um I remember when I passed I mean just
the first person I hired part time was
awesome and then when I started passing
like 10 people like wow we had 10 people
like this is I'm Legit now let's go
um but you can't like the next level of
growth comes from
uh not solving your team's problems for
them
because what do you know about CRM
software
right like that's not your expertise if
he was asking you something about
something you were good at then great
yes mentorship but what are you going to
do you're going to go research you're
going to go ask questions you're going
to go watch YouTube videos You're Gonna
Go
Google right you're going to find
answers but all of the stuff that you're
gonna do he could be doing
and so it's telling him here's what okay
you don't have the answers yet go find
out go watch the videos
right this is something this is a
conversation just out with Nina
um a couple weeks ago Nina's managing a
bunch of the people on our team
uh and it's been great because I can't
manage 43 people on the team well myself
so she's managing some of the people and
so one of the persons she's managing is
in charge of our Twitter account
Twitter is not like my number one
priority but we want to grow it so we
have somebody who's helping our Twitter
account Nina's managing that person not
me
and Nina's like I don't know anything
about Twitter
like well you don't like you don't need
to go and learn about Twitter to be able
to manage the person who's doing Twitter
like if all the ideas are coming from
you for Twitter
then it's always going to be limited by
how much you know like if the if the
ideas for CRM have to be coming from you
Tanya like then it's never gonna work
like it's just
it's just wrong thinking and then you
don't actually grow your business
so Nina is then empowering him to go in
research so they meet every week and
they talk about
the Twitter growth and one of his
assignments every week is what did you
learn this week
what did you learn did you watch your
video did you look at what other people
are doing on Twitter did you monitor
people in my industry garyvee and Grant
Cardone and Tom bilyu and Alex Hermos
and whoever and see what they're doing
on Twitter did you sign up for a
skillshare course and so it's up to them
every week to say what they learned
about Twitter and bring a recommendation
for what we should be doing next and
then Alina has to do is one make sure
that they're actually doing the work and
then two does their recommendation fit
with the brand right like Evan should go
streaking down the city in Toronto like
okay that might do really well on
Twitter but uh that's not in line with
the brand
so no we're not going to do that
um
so
that's great that you assigned it to him
the next step is I trust you to go and
do the research and find out as opposed
to I'm going to solve this problem for
you which we all default to do you know
like we'll go solve the problem because
we're used to being the how person
now it's empowering them to do it and
then his homework is okay what is it
Thursday next Thursday I want I want a
list of all the crms and he can ask you
clarifying questions about how it fits
the business but not about which tool to
go with and the technical aspects of it
sounds great yeah thank you thank you
this week's topic was Maria who picked
Niche picking one and staying with it
had a narrow when in it to include
another Niche uh well since we have
Maria here why don't we uh Workshop this
a little bit what what's uh what's on
your mind where's this coming from
thank you Evan and thank you so much for
I'm just blown away with your generosity
with the challenge and
anyway um thank you so I've been you
know I've I've shifted my Niche a few
times over the years because I I address
women that struggle in their
relationship to food Weight and Body
Image but it's typically the tip of the
iceberg and usually the deeper blocks
the emotional blocks sometimes trauma
sometimes Stress Management sometimes
that's where you have to go to have
long-term healing and so
I'm you know I I Market to that
particular population but I work with
people that struggle with anxiety and
because that's usually the next layer
right people are medicating with food
it's a lot of times they're medicating
their anxiety or their and one of the
things I just watched your interview
with Melanie because I I am a emotional
Freedom techniques Master practitioner
and that's one of the techniques that I
actually use to one of them that help
people to have more peace in their with
their emotional body so my question is
do I just stick to this Niche or do I
broaden it like when is like when is the
time to do that or do I just keep doing
what I'm doing and because for instance
I'll work with someone and then she'll
send me her husband because her husband
has anxiety issues you know so
I don't know if that's clear no no I
mean they get great and think everybody
kind of struggles with forms of this at
some point when they're figuring out
their content Their audience
um what you need to think about is who
so in in looking at your titles for the
movement makers challenge that we're
going through right now all your titles
came back to helping women right like
everything said women which is fine so
you know I love I'll believe in anybody
I like if somebody if you sent me
somebody who or I'm talking to somebody
who's an employee and never wants to be
an entrepreneur I'll still have the
conversation help them it's just not
really what I want to be doing you know
it's like it's not at the core of what I
love the most because that's I love
serving entrepreneurs more so it doesn't
mean that hey because you're a man I'm
not going to talk to you you know but if
you love serving women then you focus on
that audience first
inside of that
you get the pick is it really mental
health stuff that you love about a love
caring about is it really the weight
loss Journey because that leads to the
mental health stuff you know like who do
you love helping the most like if you
had to pick we all love serving we all
love helping if we see somebody fall on
the street we're gonna go and and help
them up I hope readers built to serve
readers okay you see somebody follow the
street you go help them up but that's
not like what we want to you know be
spending our days doing it's just we see
somebody in need and we do what we can
to support
um you know right now uh the whole thing
in Ukraine like my main video editor her
she's Ukrainian and she left three uh no
she left like five years ago from
Ukraine to go to Montenegro and
um
because of war and potential war and all
that so she's safe but her family is in
the Ukraine and we've been spending the
past time kind of figuring out hey how
how can I help I mean I'm I'm in Canada
like do they need money like is your
family safe can they fly out of the
country can they get somewhere where
they need to go you know I I don't speak
the language or have any connections but
uh if if money is a problem to get
people what they need like let me know
um and you know I'm helping with that
but it's not what I want I my mission
isn't going into war-torn countries and
helping people escape but you know right
so we do what we can to serve the people
who are around us but like who do you
who would you spend or love spending the
most time with it's like just absolutely
feeds your soul who are they and what
are they struggling with in the
challenge of the movement makers
the thing we're going through right now
is to try to get it more specific so
that when you're making the content it's
not just how to fix your anxiety
which is great but specific to like who
are the people who love helping them out
so in that context who do you who would
you love helping like the most the most
the most yeah so
my word is care and my mission really is
I feel passionate about this is to to
help women to get beyond the struggles
that undermine them so that they can
stand in their life and and be their
best self and and serve in the way that
they've been called to serve because I
feel like the advancement of women and
you know we in this country we have we
have more freedom than many women on the
planet and yet we're emotionally
oppressed by Body Image issues and
weight issues and and all that chips
away at us being our best self so I feel
passionate about that and also my story
is about that I've come from multiple
eating disorders and I've worked in so I
you know I'm on the other side of that
now and I feel like my purpose is my
passion I mean my pain has been my
passion
so yes that's that gives me greatest
pleasure when I have clients that are
you know getting beyond the dieting
stuff and and really looking you know
living a Freer life and they're and
they're finding their purpose beyond
that and not teaching their little
daughters to be over concerned about
diet and weight but that these girls can
come into the world with more empowered
about
who they are as a person not necessarily
how they look so I mean that's part of
it yeah I mean I love I love that you so
you have your Niche women which is
awesome now now that's like
half of the population so we've narrowed
it down a little bit but
getting a little more specific to then
the next step and the problem that
they're facing is helpful because if you
only said women who who aren't living
their best lives that's everybody that's
every woman that's every man too by the
way you know
separating their potential whatever so
it's very it's very broad which which is
the long-term Mission but then inside of
that who do you love helping the most
and whether it relates to food or not
that's the discussion to start to figure
out it's like hey we can we can start to
build this Niche and then expand from
there but inside of that like who do you
love love love helping the most like do
you love helping teenage girls get over
a crush that broke their heart on Prom
Night do you love helping
you know a woman who might have lost her
mom yesterday to cancer you know like
there's so many issues that we will face
and so it's great to Target women but
then what are they struggling with the
most that you love helping them through
and then that becomes
most of the content that you start with
so you can start building your tribe
around it yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it is women that are caught in in
struggling
with weight thinking they need a diet
that's going to fix them because it's
really an inside job right and so I get
great set like for instance I've been
working with a new client recently and
after a couple of weeks she's come to
the realization that it's really not
about her weight her unhappiness and her
and that gives me great gratification
and satisfaction yes she wants to still
be healthy and treat her body with
respect but giving up the struggle and
learning to trust herself more is
that that's what gives me great
gratification that she's she's really
feeling more of um taking caring enough
about herself that she is willing to
have healthier boundaries with her
husband and rather than focusing on the
body image and all of that getting
beyond that is that is that clear yeah
yeah I think that's great like behind
every for all everybody here you want to
have an impact and we all have a message
to to serve other people
these strategies alone are not going to
be enough like just telling somebody
here's what you do here's the foods to
eat if I could just tell somebody hey
make these videos go that's not enough
because there's there's emotional
resistances to everything
so you could tell somebody to eat this
food but there's a reason why they're
abusing the food in the first place all
of us have blocks that prevent us from
doing the next thing and so
understanding that really helps so
woman you're helping they're they're
stressed out or they have anxiety or
they have body issues and some of them
the ones who you'll lock up the most
they solve they they feed their anxiety
and stress with food
others might do it through drugs others
might do nothing or relationships or
they cut themselves or they you know
like and so that's where like well do
you want to help those women too if
somebody's saying like I've tried to
kill myself four times because I hate my
body and like maybe maybe you don't turn
that person away you know but it's not
like the core of what you want to deal
with because it's not the same path that
you went through right so if women great
awesome plus anxiety stress
self-confidence issues great that's
going to be everybody but how do they
fix though how are they getting their
fix off is through food
yeah and so you're still addressing the
underlying thing but also helping them
solve the connection to getting their
fix with food right so it's like food
but you're not just gonna teach diet
plans no you're going to teach them
techniques underneath it's not that
those techniques no really of course and
but it's not just that those techniques
only work through food
it could also apply to people who are
cutting themselves or oh yes or for men
too who are doing these it's just not as
much
of a connection to you because you
haven't gone through those things yeah
well I've gone through other addictive
behaviors and and and on because really
my understanding you know if you if you
just transfer one addiction to another
the expression is you're changing seats
on the Titanic I mean you're not
addressing the underlying you're still
going down right and what years ago when
I worked in an eating disorder unit by
the time people got there they had gone
through drug addiction and and gambling
addiction and so all of that stuff is
relevant and yes though as I work with
people for instance I'll work with
somebody who's a food issue and then all
of a sudden after a couple weeks they
feel safe enough with me to real to to
reveal that they drink a bottle of wine
every night and so as we uncover
the core reasons so it's you know on the
onset I I'm I tracked people and
sometimes people don't over well I guess
it has more to do with Rapport and
intimacy and Trust as they get to know
me and they feel safe with me then they
reveal more
about who they are and also knowing if
you've been through the thing that
they're going through because you can
make the connection between addictive
behaviors but other people may not right
so like have you ever lost your home
because of a gambling problem
well my father was a compulsive gambling
Gambler and we lost many homes
but so that's that speaks to like family
so my family member is doing this but
have you ever done it
have I lost a home I haven't lost a home
but I've
lost a lot I don't have a gambling issue
great so but I have an issue with
supporting men because that came out of
that Dynamic that my mother I've had in
my history I don't do that today but in
my history I've supported men and given
them a lot of money
great I'm a little ashamed of even
saying that but it was because of the
Dynamics of the gambling you know so
that was well listen you're in a safe
space and thank you for having the
courage to share that with us if you
haven't told other people before but
these are things that you can speak to
right it's not that if somebody has
their own gambling problem
um you won't help them but it's just not
it's not you you you didn't go and lose
your home but if somebody came and said
my father has again or my mother or
somebody my family has a gambling
addiction or I keep supporting people
for some reason why do I keep supporting
these men who have gambling problems
what is wrong with me like somebody that
person you would love helping so much
more than I have a gambling problem
because it's more through your
experience of what you've lived like if
somebody came to you and said I keep
supporting men who have gambling
problems what's wrong with me and then
you help them realize there's nothing
wrong with you
right and you teach them to actually
love herself and just get out of these
negative relationships that's going to
make you feel amazing yes so it's and I
hope I mean we're spending a lot of time
on this but hopefully everybody can see
that kind of similar Journey for your
own self the thing that you have been
through where you felt hopeless
worthless like when your dad did that
and you lost your home or you gave money
and
just how terrible like it made you feel
terrible about yourself and if you then
subsidize through food like okay well
I'm just gonna go eat that pizza or
Doritos or whatever just to make me feel
good because I don't have any happiness
in my life anywhere right like this is
where people get really stuck so that's
your Niche you know the people who are
currently struggling with a thing that
you struggled through and it doesn't
mean we ignore everybody else we can't
help them and we're going to turn them
away but it's not who we're actively
trying to go out and serve because if
you just go out and say ladies have more
self-confidence it becomes too broad a
message
but then you end up we end up trying to
serve everybody and ends up serving very
few people
does that help yes it's very helpful I
have one more so
so the modalities that I do use is
tapping and I really love the
conversation you had with Melanie
because it's not all the only thing I
use and but a lot of my YouTube videos
have been focused on that because
there's a whole niche of people that are
but I use the tapping specific to that
weight body image and
so so like who I how right that from
Bill to serve that's the how the how the
how matters less about what the how is
and matters more that you believe in the
how like if if somebody sees you and say
I'm in the same situation as Maria I've
been over eating to combat my stress
because of whatever happened in my life
and you're gonna say I'm exactly like
you here's how I got through it tapping
great show me how to do it like the how
does it matter
what matters is that it actually worked
for you yeah and that because I love you
and I connect to your story I'm gonna
now have more belief in the strategy
that you're gonna give me on how to get
out as well so if tapping helped you
then incorporate into your content yes
if it helped you for everything great
put it everywhere if it helped you only
for specific problems just make it for
those specific problems but bringing it
into your content bring it into your
coaching whatever got you out of the
hole
is the thing then you teach other people
because that's your job is to get them
out of the hole that they're in as well
and we all have we all have different
house right and you don't have to use
the same have for every situation but
how did you get out of the situation you
were in and now we teach that yeah we're
thought leaders
I love it it just reminds me of somebody
booked a consult with me tomorrow and
when I when somebody books I ask them to
just put anything that they have to say
and she said she said I'm not sure about
tapping but I'm sure about you she's
been following me for a while yeah and
um it really just spoke to what you were
saying she felt comfortable enough to
have the consult with me to potentially
work with me but she wasn't sure about
tapping yeah like the how does it matter
this is why in movement makers for this
challenge that we're doing when when I'm
rejecting everybody putting in their
like their four steps to do things or
the three ways or the age like the
strategies do not matter
what matters is the connection to you I
don't giving me eight strategies is not
the benefit
what's the specific the specific benefit
that I'm gonna get from working with you
and so that's the whole game if you get
them to to know you like you trust you
which comes from you telling your story
if I start talking about women's weight
issues
you're not a woman you don't know me you
don't know what I'm going through right
like it's going to be the first like who
even if I have all the same strategies
they're not gonna listen to me because
I'm not a woman
right and and that's an obvious like
hopefully you can tell that I'm not a
woman
like that's a pretty obvious thing but
the thing is a lot of these things that
we
have struggled with are not obvious like
knowing that you struggled if I look at
you I don't think you struggle with food
if I look at you I don't think you had
men in your life who had gambling issues
that you supported so when you come out
and say Here's how you solve it it
doesn't come across like who is this
woman who's preaching to me
right you're not and this is hopefully
applicable to everybody like you're not
coming down from your high horse and
preaching people and telling people what
to do you're saying I'm just like you I
was I was in the same spot and I
struggled with this and here's how I
overcame but until you share that story
and I know that you've been through it
and you're at you're like me then then
I'm not going to listen to you so anyway
most things are not obvious right men
women obvious you know ethnic background
whatever scar on your face like super
obvious but most of the things we deal
with is not obvious and so we need to
share those things and have the courage
and you honestly did it right here it's
like I'm a little embarrassed to say
this it's great
and sharing that will only connect more
people to you like nobody if any people
only feel more love for you in saying
that you struggled with supporting men
who had gambling addictions not oh I'm
not going to talk to Maria now because
of that so thank you for having the
courage to uh to share up thank you Evan
thank you for all that you do thank you
all right we got Chris in the house what
do we got man I just bought the book
recently um a friend of mine out in
Amsterdam uh told me to get the book
um kind of trying to make a long story
as short as possible I used to be a very
overweight person
um and I'm in my late 40s and I started
diving into uh natural bodybuilding
meaning you know no steroids and all
that stuff to get into shape and um 47
and
I got the little trophies and stuff
behind me back there I actually have
done pretty well and I've really found
that to be my passion I didn't find my
who when I was doing my pages like at
the uh the first five questions who
inspired you and yada yada
uh so I guess I'm kind of lost as what
how to get that get to that point what's
my uh hashtag me you know what I mean
like I want to say determination because
you know going from like close to 300
pounds down to about 160 that took a lot
of daggone determination I couldn't just
stayed motivated motivation lasts about
a week but staying determined to get up
at four in the morning and eat the egg
whites and all that other stuff that
goes into it especially in my 40s was
determination and but you know it's not
just about making money although I I can
retire from my current job in about two
years and not having to punch a clock
anymore perhaps making money as a
personal trainer would be something I'd
rather do than you know work for
somebody but again it's not about the
money necessarily it's about maybe
helping someone else that's uh
been in that same situation where they
were dealing with the problems of being
overweight and what can they overcome to
not you know have those so would you
prefer Christopher or Chris or you don't
care Chris I just sorry okay Christopher
because Christopher is what your mom
calls you okay so you know I'm in
trouble yeah
so Chris go back and like think about
what year was the worst moment of your
life
like how old were you I don't know
probably in my maybe 42-43 well my son
had maybe even younger my son had cancer
in his eye and that was one hell of a
rough goal
um so I was probably more like
as 25 26 years old okay so if you think
about going back to 25 year old Chris
and or 42 year old Chris what do you
what are you gonna sit down and tell
them
um well as far as the cancer was
concerned the only thing we could do is
just go through the process and let my
son heal
um no no but you're gonna like you're
sitting like imagine Chris who's
devastated right now that he's going
through this and all the sleepless
nights and all the emotion and the pain
and and you have five minutes to go sit
at a park bench and talk to that guy
what are you gonna tell him not just oh
we just got to go to you're not gonna
tell him we're just gonna go through the
process so what do you actually tell
that Chris
you can get through this and um
you know
you you've got you got to put your faith
in God and and move forward
I guess
that's great
how about how about how about 42 year
old Chris who's struggling with weight
being massively overweight what are you
telling him
it's your fault you don't you know you
can blame genetics all day but that
quarter pounder with cheese wasn't
genetic and nor was that large pizza and
six pack of beer okay but you're
probably not slamming him you're
probably not putting him down and saying
it's your fault because that Chris
doesn't want to hear it's my fault
because you already hate yourself at
that point
it's your fault as like the achiever
it's the Chris now saying okay let's
change our lives but right 42 year old
Chris can't hear that message because
he's too he hates his life so what do
you tell that guy
um let's get to work because uh the same
this didn't happen overnight and it's
not gonna fix itself overnight but we
have to get to work to get it started
so in in those messages
is at the core of what you're all about
so I wrote down from the first one was
faith and move forward
okay the second one like from the from
your son with the like and your son's
better by the way I hope oh gosh yeah
he's doing great he's good so he's doing
phenomenal yeah cool so you know Faith
moving forward
and then from the second one was let's
get to work get started
okay
in there in that combination is what
you want to give to the world
right
and so I would I would play with those
keywords as like the the who is on top
and then The Credo is underneath of the
three things that make it up right I
can't come and tell you hey Chris it's
this right like this is this whole
exercise where you have to figure it out
but it will feel more and more right
so like maybe determined is part of it
but at the top is actually faith
maybe your messages to give Faith like
Choice 25 year old Chris needed Faith 42
year old Chris needed Faith as well and
under faith is hey let's get to work
let's get started be determined and
something else right if you play with
those combinations of keywords but when
you can actually get out of your head
and into emotion that's where it's going
to ring more true so when I you know
interrupted you and said hey no no you
wouldn't actually say that you're not
going to tell them it's your fault and
you're not going to tell the other one
just listen to the doctors and we'll be
fine like you're going to have a more
like this is what we do though we we
just stay in our head and strategic but
this is a heart
question so you would actually have a
lot more compassion
um and so I mean thank you for being a
guinea pig and and sharing but in that
combination we'll just feel more and
more right so I would sit on all four of
those faith move forward let's get to
work get started I mean let's get to
work and get started are kind of similar
anyway but there might be difference in
the the meaning for you
uh and then there is the solution
okay
thank you yeah and don't stress if it
doesn't come tonight but with more time
like you sleep on it come back
Faith might feel more right or move
forward might feel more and more right
okay right or maybe determination you
know maybe that is it too but I feel
more and more right but with you and
that's actually exercise for everybody
and I know we're a little bit over but
exercise for everybody's like what would
you tell think about the most painful
moment in your life go back what would
you tell him or her
on an emotional level to sit with them
and understand like you think about the
pain that they're going through and and
now the perspective if you know of
course is now going back like 20 years
there's a lot of perspective that's
happened in that time that you can you
can give that person younger you a lot
more
um knowledge and wisdom in a way that
they would listen
and you'd be a lot more compassionate so
I would tell 1911 hey believe dude
believe like believe in yourself believe
that it will work out believe that
you're gonna make it that you will get
through this like you just need more
belief because you've got all the can I
tell you what 42 41 42 year 11 looks
like it's amazing you're gonna love your
life out there the thing that you need
right now just more belief like that's
me at 41 19 you're 11. and so that's
what I still need now and you can find
like if it ends up on faith as an
example it's still what you need now
right for everything that you've done
and you've lost the weight and your son
is healthy you won these trophies and
everything else you've hit a certain
level and the difference between now and
where you could be in five years is
still a deeper level of faith
sure determination or whatever you come
up with right and this is where people
might look at you and say but you're
already so determined dude
right you already have so much
determination but there's another level
to unlock
right right okay
um cool well thank you thank you for
showing up and thank you for asking the
question if you want to get a copy of
Bill to serve and join us live for our
next training with me to ask your
questions you can go get the book right
there next to me right there I'll see
you there I'll see you at the get the
book it's a good one much love